well they are calling it a step in the
right direction emma berkey expected to
come home today
after months of battling very rare brain
blood clots after receiving the johnson
and johnson vaccine
christian casadas has an update on this
case which has her family now
very hopeful kristen that's right denise
well she's getting better every single
day that's how emma's mother reacted to
the discharge on social media
on a post a long road for emma and her
family which is taking a turn
for the better now these are images
emma's family shared on social media
recently
as the 18 year old teenager gets ready
to leave a loma linda hospital in
southern california
she underwent three brain surgeries
after suffering a stroke
emma was one of six women in the nation
who suffered a rare but severe blood
clocks back in april
after getting the single dose johnson
johnson vaccine the family pastor
and spokesperson tells us that her left
body is not fully responding including
her left leg
which is preventing her to walk the
recovery road has been
long and far from over honestly they
didn't know if she would make it
and so that's been three months now
three and a half months and
she is alert communicative
hasn't lost any of her personality all
of her cognitive abilities have been
there
what has been affected are her some of
her physical
function which they're really really
really working hard
to repair and rehabilitate
on monday the fda warned the johnson and
johnson vaccine can lead to an increased
risk of a rare neurological condition
a rare syndrome that one in every
million develop every year in the u.s
a gofundme page has generated over 60
thousand dollars for emma
and that amount keeps growing if you'd
like to donate to a recovery we have a
link on our website eight newsnow dot
com now the next step
is transferring emma to las vegas and
finding the medical tools she needs
the family expressed their gratitude for
the support and the prayers from the
community
they say it's giving them hope christian
gossip is 8 news now